andy richter how are you andy i'm good
thanks how are you
i'm pretty good you know like the rest
of us waiting
uh patiently uh happy to wait
uh for uh for the vaccine you know you
keep hearing every week they
they announce new categories like who's
eligible
and i think this week they're starting
to say that is it teachers are eligible
now here in california
uh yeah i'm i i signed up on the website
and i'm just waiting to hear
yeah until they tell me it's okay i'm
just right
you just wanna you know until it's until
it's our time we're happy to wait
uh but every now and then you like to
know what category is up
yeah so just before we started taping
today i asked my assistant
uh i said sona can you hear me yeah sona
speak
up i can hear you remember sona uh
when i came in today and i said oh sona
i'm just curious
about the new categories for who's
eligible to get uh
to get a vaccine i'm curious if they've
announced my category yet
national treasure
that got a pretty big laugh here when i
said it earlier now people are just
embarrassed for me
or they're just embarrassed to be laugh
at that on tape
yeah yeah sona did you take me seriously
when i was asking you earlier you
started off acting like you were gonna
say something legitimate and then when
you said that i just stopped paying
attention
you were all ready to like check on the
computer to see if a man
my age is it gonna be three weeks is it
gonna be four weeks and you asked me
what the category was and i said
national treasure
nothing i'm telling you when i first
said that
killed in here and yeah killed even the
cardboard cutouts were laughing
everyone thought nicholas cage was
promoting something
oh boy nope we'll just wait we'll just
wait